Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Ben, qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Plus rien ne fonctionne.
Mais non, rassurez-vous,
ce n'est pas encore le redouté blackout,
mais ça pourrait arriver.
Et le responsable ?
On le connaît tous.
C'est lui ! Notre Soleil.
Un soleil qui nous plonge dans le noir.
Allez, direction l'atelier.
Il est temps de faire rayonner le savoir.
Voici l'astre solaire photographié
par la sonde Solar
Orbiter, le 7 mars dernier.
Notre étoile est une gigantesque
boule de gaz brûlants.
Son diamètre mesure 1400000 kilomètres,
110 fois celui de notre planète.
Il est composé d'hydrogène
74% et d'hélium 25%.
Il concentre à lui seul
99,8% de toute la matière du système solaire.
La température de son cœur
atteint 15 millions de degrés.
C'est un gigantesque réacteur nucléaire
qui produit de l'énergie.
Toute cette chaleur met plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'années à remonter
jusqu'à sa surface où elle est libérée
sous forme de rayonnement.
Alors, il y a bien sûr la lumière visible,
mais aussi des infrarouges,
des ultraviolets
et beaucoup d'autres rayonnements
que je ne vais pas citer ici.
Ensuite, ça va très vite.
Il faut huit minutes à la lumière
pour parcourir
les 150 millions de kilomètres
qui séparent
le Soleil de la Terre.
Ces chiffres sont astronomiques.
Pour vous donner une meilleure idée,
si le Soleil faisait la taille
de cette pastèque,
la Terre ne serait pas plus grosse
que le quart de ce pépin de citron.
Et il serait situé
à 300 mètres de la pastèque.
C'est comme si la pastèque se trouvait
au pied de la tour Eiffel.
Et le pépin de citron à son sommet.
J'y suis peut-être allé
un peu fort, mais du coup,
vu la distance,
de quoi faut-il s'inquiéter ?
Des coups de soleil, certes,
mais pas seulement.
Suis-moi.
Comme la Terre,
le Soleil possède un champ magnétique.
La différence, c'est qu'il varie beaucoup
plus vite que celui de notre planète.
Rendez-vous compte,
les pôles Nord et Sud
solaires s'inversent en moyenne
tous les onze ans.
Pour vous donner une idée,
la dernière inversion sur Terre
s'est produite
il y a grosso modo 780000 ans.
Mais revenons au Soleil.
C'est-ce que les scientifiques appellent
le cycle solaire.
Ce cycle rythme
l'activité du Soleil
et la quantité d'énergie
que notre étoile libère dans l'espace.
Cette énergie ne se présente pas
d'ailleurs uniquement
sous forme de lumière.
Le Soleil émet aussi
un flux de particules chargées
électriquement.
C'est ce qu'on appelle "le vent solaire".
Notre planète baigne donc en permanence
dans un nuage de particules.
Le problème, c'est que ce flux continu
est plus ou moins puissant
en fonction de l'activité du Soleil.
Quand l'activité magnétique
s'emballe, le Soleil
libère d'énormes quantités d'énergie.
Ce sont les fameuses tempêtes solaires.
Et lorsque l'activité solaire
est vraiment très intense,
d'immenses nuages de particules
chargées et de rayonnements
sont parfois crachés dans l'espace.
On parle alors
d'éjection de masse coronale.
Une tempête XXL
qui voyage à plus de 2 millions
de kilomètres par heure.
Imaginez un peu
la puissance de ces colères.
Une seule éruption solaire
peut dégager une quantité
d'énergie électrique équivalente à celle
qui serait consommée sur Terre
en 100000 ans, voire 1 million d'années.
Finalement, je vais peut-être en remettre une couche.
Pas de panique, la plupart du temps,
notre planète n'a rien à craindre
des humeurs du Soleil.
Elle dispose d'un duo de choc
l'atmosphère et le bouclier
créé par le champ magnétique terrestre,
qu'on appelle
la magnétosphère.
Et ce n'est pas de la science-fiction.
L'atmosphère, qui forme une couche
d'environ 700 kilomètres
d'épaisseur, stoppe
une grande partie des rayons UV.
Elle constitue un premier bouclier.
La magnétosphère, ensuite, agit
jusqu'à 60000 kilomètres
au dessus de nos têtes.
Elle nous protège contre les nuages
de particules chargés
que le Soleil nous envoie.
Cependant,
le bouclier magnétique terrestre
a un point faible, ou plutôt deux
au niveau des pôles ici et là.
C'est par ici
que les premiers effets de l'activité
du Soleil, de ses colères surtout,
peuvent se faire sentir sur Terre.
On parle alors de tempêtes géomagnétiques.
Une des manifestations les plus courantes
de ces tempêtes géomagnétiques,
ce sont les aurores polaires.
Ces lumières vertes, rouges,
parfois violettes ou roses,
qui embrasent le ciel au pôle Nord
et au pôle Sud,
naissent de la rencontre brutale
entre certaines particules
des nuages solaires
et les gaz présents dans notre atmosphère.
Mais c'est magnifique une aurore polaire.
Et ça n'a rien de dangereux.
Non, tu as raison.
Mais l'activité solaire
peut avoir des conséquences beaucoup plus sérieuses.
Lorsque cet énorme
nuage de particules solaires
atteint notre atmosphère.
Il déforme sa couche supérieure.
Cette déformation descend
jusqu'à 80 kilomètres de la Terre.
La tempête géomagnétique
a alors des conséquences directes
sur les systèmes de communication.
La transmission des signaux satellites
qui dépendent
de la stabilité de l'atmosphère
est faussée.
Les avions et les navires qui s'appuient
sur ces satellites
et leurs données GPS pour s'orienter
peuvent se retrouver
temporairement privés
de systèmes de navigation.
Un vrai cauchemar en termes de sécurité.
Le fonctionnement des satellites
peut carrément être interrompu.
Endommagés par le bombardement
des particules solaires.
Le 4 février 2022.
Une tempête géomagnétique a ainsi
mis hors service
une quarantaine de satellites Starlink
qui venaient tout juste d'être déployés par Space X.
Ils n'ont pas pu se placer
en orbite
et se sont désintégrés
en retombant dans l'atmosphère.
Je savais bien qu'il ne fallait pas s'en
débarrasser de ces cartes routières.
Et en cas de tempête géomagnétique,
les activités en altitude ou dans l'espace
présentent aussi un risque réel
pour la santé humaine.
Au sol, nous sommes protégés par le double
bouclier de l'atmosphère
et du champ magnétique terrestre.
Mais là haut, ce n'est pas le cas.
Pour les astronautes
à bord de la Station spatiale
internationale
qui ne sont pas protégés par ce bouclier.
Les radiations peuvent être dangereuses.
C'est pour cette raison
que certaines zones à bord sont équipées
pour mieux résister aux rayonnements
provoqués par les tempêtes.
Même chose pour le personnel
navigant des compagnies aériennes.
Les lignes qui survolent
les régions polaires les plus exposées
aux tempêtes géomagnétiques
sont parfois déviées
pour éviter aux équipages d'être
trop exposés
à ces radiations.
Autre risque
lié aux tempêtes géomagnétiques,
les fameux blackouts.
Bouh !
les nuages de particules solaires chargés
peuvent produire des effets
de courants électriques
induits au voisinage du sol terrestre.
Ces courants peuvent perturber
le fonctionnement des lignes à haute
tension, allant parfois jusqu'à griller
les transformateurs en bout de ligne
et provoquer des pannes générales
d'électricité.
C'est ce qui s'est produit
au Québec en 1989.
Plus de 6 millions de personnes
se sont retrouvées sans électricité
alors qu'on était encore au mois de mars.
Ben tiens, j'ai bien eu raison
de ne pas me séparer de ma lampe torche
qui fonctionne avec des piles.
Ben oui, s'il n'y a plus d'électricité,
impossible de recharger son téléphone
et de s'éclairer avec.
Tiens, d'ailleurs, ça pourrait se reproduire ?
En théorie, oui.
D'après les calculs d'une équipe
internationale de scientifiques,
on aurait déjà évité le pire.
Dans la nuit du 22 au 23 juillet 2012,
deux éruptions solaires
presque simultanées ont provoqué
la plus puissante éjection de particules
solaires jamais observée.
Heureusement pas
dans la direction de la Terre.
La super tempête géomagnétique
qui aurait pu avoir lieu
aurait eu des conséquences estimées
à 2 600 milliardsde dollars de dégâts.
Le blackout
et la désorganisation sur Terre
auraient été gigantesques.
Je vais demander à Elon Musk
de me réserver
une place
dans sa prochaine fusée pour Mars.
Je serai plus en sécurité là bas.
Attends quand même un peu pour embarquer.
Le prochain blackout n'est pas prévu
pour demain.
Les scientifiques qui étudient
le phénomène ont remarqué
que les éruptions les plus violentes
se produisent en général
sur des étoiles plus jeunes
que notre Soleil.
Ben oui.
Avec ses 5 milliards d'années,
il en est déjà
à la moitié de son existence.
Il n'est plus aussi actif
que dans sa première jeunesse.
Et même en cas d'éruption solaire majeure,
il faudrait en plus
qu'elle se produise
en direction de notre planète.
Et d'après les scientifiques, c'est
très hypothétique.
Ça manque un peu de soleil ici.
Ah, ça fait du bien.
D'autant qu'aujourd'hui,
le soleil est sous haute surveillance
grâce aux télescopes,
aux satellites, aux sondes
qui permettent
d'étudier notre étoile au plus près
et comprendre les mécanismes
de déclenchement des éruptions solaires.
Parmi ces mécanismes,
les taches solaires intéressent
plus particulièrement les scientifiques.
Ce sont des zones sombres visibles
à la surface de notre étoile.
Elles sont plus froides
que la surface du Soleil
et le siège d'une intense
activité magnétique.
Or, elles apparaissent
peu de temps avant les éruptions.
La présence,
le nombre et la forme des tâches solaires
est donc un bon indicateur d'éventuelles
tempêtes
géomagnétiques à venir.
Toutes ces informations, couplées
à des mesures magnétiques sur Terre,
permettent de diffuser aujourd'hui
des bulletins quotidiens de météorologie
spatiale
évaluant les risques à court
et moyen
terme de coupures des télécommunications
ou d'impacts potentiels
pour le personnel navigant.
Mesdames et Messieurs, bonsoir !
L'activité géomagnétique s'annonce
perturbée pour les prochaines 24h.
Avec, vous le voyez, un pic auroral
annoncé au dessus du Canada,
mais rien de très méchant.
Malgré tout, cela
augure quelques perturbations
au niveau des satellites géostationnaires.
Demain, nous fêtons les Jamy 2.
Oui bon,
le prochain pic d'activité solaire,
justement, avec le risque d'éruption
importante, est attendu pour 2025.
On a le temps de voir venir
Comment le sait-on ?
Et bien, souvenez-vous, le fameux cycle
solaire de onze ans
qui rythme notre astre.
Le dernier s'est achevé en 2020,
en fin de cycle.
On est alors
au plus bas de l'activité.
Du coup, le cycle durant onze ans,
je le répète, en 2025 2026,
on sera à mi-parcours du cycle,
donc au plus fort de l'activité,
avant qu'elle ne décline à nouveau
jusqu'en 2031.
Qu'un cycle s'achève,
et qu'un nouveau redémarre.
Voilà, ça nous laisse
donc le temps de voir venir.
Et puis désormais,
vous ne serez plus surpris
parce que vous en connaissez
un rayon sur les colères du soleil.
Allez, je m'éclipse
jusqu'à la prochaine vidéo.